and we continue our coverage of
Hurricane durian officials in the
Bahamas expect the number of people
killed from the hurricane to rise
significantly the storm is blamed at
this time for more than four at least
thirty deaths so far and thousands of
people are reported missing search and
rescue missions around the clock
continue and to get a sense of the
devastation take a look at these images
from space that shows some of the
hardest hit areas of the islands before
and after durian struck the US Coast
Guard says it's rescued more than 200
people so far CBS this morning lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is in the country's capital of Nassau
David you traveled with a group
delivering aid to one of the Bahamas
barrier islands yeah we traveled with
chef Jose Andres who is feeding people
look by now you've seen the images of
the devastation I want you to hear the
stories that's what's so important here
that will convey to you the type of
humanitarian crisis that continues this
morning and is only getting worse
the chef had a seat on his helicopter it
was packed with food he allowed us to go
with him here's what we saw we took off
from Nassau with a helicopter full of
hope so much water fruit and food that
some of it was nearly in chef Jose
Andres his lap he wasn't mad about that
he was unhappy with this piece I blame
myself today things go well we're gonna
deliver 7500 meals but for me this is
powerful what we are supposed to be
doing already the first place we landed
was Green Turtle key and the Abaco
Islands people were waiting as the
chef's offloaded food we went to ask
people what they need homes homes she
yelled in this community of about 550
people it looked as though most every
structure was either damaged or
destroyed including the food stores
and that is why the delivery from chef
Ondrea Sui matters and he didn't just
bring food from here the chef headed for
treasure K he landed on a tennis court
and was welcomed with caution this right
here right now has only been allowed to
be used so far for Coast Guard this help
there what we set up here was for
emergency evacuations they didn't know
him and the man in the orange shirt
wanted his business card the chef walked
over to the community center and asked
them what they need for this community
of about 1,500 people to cook before
leaving we asked volunteer fireman Greg
Johnson to assess the conditions for
people getting violent angry upset and
we're trying to get our government
officials if you guys do see this please
come down here and show your faces we
need you guys to show your faces here so
the people could understand and know
that you guys care at this point in time
we are on our own and the u.s. is the
only place that is helping us okay on
top of that let me just say this what
you saw in that in that piece really
conveys what is going on here there's
there's no real leader sort of in the
field so the chef is landing wherever he
can find a spot and people there are
sort of taking on leadership roles and
the chef said to me yesterday I've been
asking the government tell me where to
go tell me where you need food to be
delivered and I'll go there specifically
but he says as of right now he's not
getting an answer so he's going wherever
he hears food is needed
landing and trying to give it out at
they'll take it Jericka Wow David beg no
force in the Bahamas thank you oh my
gosh the desperation confusion on the
ground then in the aftermath of the
storm like this and he said you saw it
right there at David's piece in that
moment what do you need homes yeah yeah
yeah yeah